The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The engines,
the aircraft engines,
have a lot of sensors on them
because the engines really
need to work reliably.
So it tends to be more sort of
thermal structural components.
And my sense is in cars, you
monitor more electronics,
how many--
AUDIENCE: Emissions.
PROFESSOR: --certainly
admissions.
It's slightly different
what's being monitored,
and the sensors are different.
Even the companies that
provide these sensors
and health-monitoring equipment
tend to be different as well.
I think, there are
similar trends,
but they're somewhat parallel.
I don't think one
came before the other.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Hey,
Volcker, do you want
to mention something about
health monitoring in general
for operations?
GUEST SPEAKER: I just sent
you a link on your email
because we've been for six
years monitoring the health
of [INAUDIBLE] that's up there.
And it's live link,
so I don't know
if you are able from
your computer to open it.
I just sent you the
link on your email.
Right?
So actually, into
the first satellite
that we both [INAUDIBLE]
few years ago,
we figured we want
to know everything.
So the primary [? dom ?]
system were all
sent on every telemetry data
the same [? dom ?] at every path
and kept actual.
So maybe after break or
whenever there's a chance,
go to the link, and you can see
the actual housekeeping data.
And you'll see that the
battery, the voltage,
is the only one
that's [INAUDIBLE]..
Likely, [INAUDIBLE] of
the six years, which
is not bad for a VC system.
PROFESSOR: Yup, OK, I'll
pull it up during the break.
Thanks for that.
That'll be interesting.
OK, let's move on.
So unfortunately, I
would say the F-18,
and there's a lot of systems
that were designed with
operational excellence in mind--
maintainability,
high reliability.
That was a big thing.
I did mention this
before, I think,
but I just want to say that
it's not always the case.
So this is one of the
counter-examples, the space
shuttle.
And I have a lot of respect.
Don't misunderstand me.
I think people that worked on
the shuttle did an amazing job.
It was an amazing vehicle.
But things turned
out quite differently
than what was promised.
I think that everybody
will agree with that.
So this is a paper
that was actually
a very short paper
published believe it or not
in nature in 2011 right after
the retirement of the shuttle
and by Pilcke et al.
And what they did is,
they looked at the costs
of the shuttle program.
And the cost is well
known because this
is all public money.
This is all money that was
appropriated by Congress.
And then the light blue
bars are the number
of launches that happen
in a particular year.
So you can see the
maximum was nine--
nine launches in 1984--
not a launch a week that
Congress had been told.
And so we have about
10 years of design,
build, test until initial
operating capability.
And then we have about 30
years of actually usage
and operations.
And this is true for any system.
The operational phase is much
longer than the design phase.
So in this case, the
operational phase
was 30 years right, three times
longer than the actual design
phase, which was about a decade.
The Vision was a partially
reusable space vehicle,
quick turnaround,
high flight rate.
What we actually got is a
complex and fragile vehicle
with an average cost of
about $1.5 billion for flight
and a workforce of
about 20,000 people
to keep the shuttle flying.
And I think I've shown
you this before, right?
Did I show you this before?
So this is an
original illustration
from the proposal to Congress.
It kind of looks like the
F-18 that I just showed you.
It's a hangar,
pristine, a few people,
a couple of ground
support equipment carts--
this is kind of like an
airplane, like an airliner.
And then this is
what we actually got.
This is a picture taken in the
Orbiter Processing Facility
at the Kennedy Space Center.
And you can't even see
the shuttle, right?
It's hidden behind
the scaffolding,
and the main systems
that required
a lot of work between
flights were the shuttle
main engine and of course the
TPS, the thermal protection
system.
Now, you can say, well why such
a big discrepancy between what
was promised, the Vision, and
what's actually delivered?
And people will have
different opinions.
My opinion is, certainly
over-optimism was a part of it.
But also Congress kept
the research development
costs for the Orbiter in
particular to about 5.1,
5 billion.
There was actually
an act of Congress
that said those shall not
spend more 5.1, 5 billion
on development of the Orbiter.
So then, when it was clear, 24
metric tons to low-earth orbit.
If you can't achieve that,
the system will not satisfy.
So performance is king,
and of course, this
was also a politically
challenging
because there were
military requirements
and civilian requirements
that had to be met.
And then maintainability,
like I said,
just doesn't happen
automatically.
You have to actually
write requirements
for maintainability.
How long should it take?
How many hours of work?
How many actions or procedures
to do certain maintenance
actions?
It has to be designed
into the system, therefore
the need for requirements.
And then no realistic lifecycle
cost or value optimization.
So that's, I think,
the counter-example.
But again, I am not blaming
individuals for this.
I'm blaming the system for this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: To what
extent do you think
that kind of problems
within shuttle
can be traced to effectively
a failure to stop
defining the requirements?
I feel like when you look
at commercial launch systems
kind of as a comparison point.
And I understand
they're not reusable.
And they're not being
designed to necessarily
the same specifications
as shuttle.
But I feel like because the
commercial launch industry
has had standards set by
NASA and the Air Force
that they needed
to meet, that they
had a very clear
set of requirements
from the beginning.
Whereas the
development of shuttle,
like the failure to design
for maintainability,
when I look at the
development cycle,
it looks like they continue
to refine requirements
as they went and kind of
discovered new things.
And then said, OK, so we need
to do it this way instead
of saying from the beginning,
these departments we
know we have to meet.
Let's design to that.
PROFESSOR: Right, though I--
AUDIENCE: It look
like they kind of
crept through the
development phase
to me, that there
was no hard stop.
So I was just wondering if you
could comment on that kind of--
PROFESSOR: It's
definitely true that there
was sort of reacting to--
and after the first few--
so an interesting history there
is the shuttle main engines.
They were completely
disassembled and inspected
after the first
couple of flights.
But that wasn't supposed
to be done every flight.
It was supposed to be,
you're going to launch them,
I think, like five times
before you actually
do big inspections.
But they had already
done inspections
after every test flight.
And then they just
kept doing it.
So something that was supposed
to be only a maintenance
action or inspection
during test flights
became or crept into becoming
an operational requirement.
And of course, you
have a big workforce
and there's jobs and so forth.
So there's that too.
But it was never intended
that the shuttle main engines
would be disassembled and
rebuilt after every flight.
AUDIENCE: Why was
that permitted?
PROFESSOR: Well,
I guess, the sense
was that it would
be safer to do that,
and that you really
want to know what's
the state of these engines.
And I will say this, I
mean at the contractual,
there's jobs there.
There's money there.
And so the more maintenance
actions you can do,
the more of a business this is.
But of course, that's
not what the Vision was.
The Vision was a very lean,
operations, few people.
So there's a socioeconomic
things tied up with it as well.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
because that's inherently
a government project
that's part of the reason?
Like whereas a
commercial company
is looking to cut as many
employees as possible
to increase profit margin?
PROFESSOR: I think that
that's a part of it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I do
think that's a part of it.
Yeah, absolutely, it's a
really interesting history.
There's a lot to be
learned from this.
OK, so let me move on.
So this is kind of a list, not
a checklist really, but a list
of operational considerations
that you should think
about when you design a system.
So how will it be operated?
And of course, we've done
the CONOPS a while ago,
but this is sort of more
detailed than the CONOPS.
How will you inspect the system?
How will you maintain it?
What insights do the operators
need into the system status?
So when you are
operating the system,
how much about the
internal workings
do you really need to know?
This is the internal telemetry
temperatures, pressures,
in the avionics, the electrical.
I think the example of the
electrical bus was good,
the cryogenics system example,
how much insight do you need?
Before turning over to the
operators, what checks do
you need to perform?
How might the system fail?
Think about failure,
and you of course
need to think about that
as early as possible.
What are the options
available to you
in case you have failures?
And you will have failures.
What spares are needed
to repair the system?
Will this system still perform
even under partial failure?
So maybe something failed
but not catastrophically.
It's a partial failure.
Can you keep going
with the system?
How far can you push the system?
I think if you think about this
is like five questions here,
but I think, they are five of
the most important questions
for operations.
Now in terms of
the NASA lifecycle,
we're talking Phase E
here, just to be clear.
So Phase E is called
Operations and Sustainment.
And depending on what
mission you're talking about,
this could be short--
like the Apollo missions, like
two weeks and they're back
home--
ISS, six months rotations.
Or it could be
something like Voyager.
Voyager was launched
when in '76?
Voyager's been
flying for 40 years,
and we're still getting data
and telemetry at very low data
rates, like 100 bits per
second or something like this.
But still, that's
remarkable, right?
So Phase E, in that
case, is very long.
So it's worth really
thinking about this.
All right, let me talk
about commissioning.
So commissioning is
essentially the transition
from Phase D to
Phase E. So Phase D
is System Assembly,
Integration, Test, and Launch,
and Transition to Use.
And Phase E is then
Operations and Sustainment.
So to conduct the mission, meet
the initially-identified need,
maintain support,
and then implement
your mission operations plan.
So commissioning,
essentially, is transitioning
from Phase D to
Phase E. And usually,
the people that will operate
the system day in, day out,
tend to be different
people than the people who
design the system, who build the
system, who launch the system.
So usually, you have some
kind of a handoff or handover
of the system from the
designers, builders
to the operators.
And that handover is very
important that it be done well.
And that's what we
call commissioning.
Or in this case, this is
the-- do you remember this?
We haven't shown
this for a while.
Remember what do we call
this, this thing here?
The engine, right?
The system's engineering
engine at every level.
So this is Step 9, Product
Transitioning Process.
And then there has to
be a flow chart, right?
Can't do without a flow chart.
It's not particularly
fancy or anything,
but the idea is that
you have inputs,
which are the end product,
ready to be used, documentation.
So when I ask you about
the cryogenic system--
you mentioned the
cryogenic system--
I ask you, do you have
a user manual for it?
So that would be here, in this
box here, on the left side--
the documentation that
goes with the end product.
And then any product
transition-enabling products,
so those would be
things that you only
use during the transition,
like equipment or facilities
that you just use for this
transitioning process.
And then you don't use
them during operations.
You can think of
examples of that.
And then you go through
this multiple steps.
There may be multiple sites
that you have to prepare,
multiple locations.
And at the end of it, you've
delivered the end product.
It's operational,
transition work products,
and you're essentially
operational.
So what it means in
practice is deploying
the system in the field,
transitioning to the operators,
physically and legally also--
I should point this out.
This is really important.
So usually, in this
commissioning phase,
the legal ownership of
the product or the asset
is transferred from one
organization to the other.
So if it breaks now,
it's your problem.
It's not my problem.
You've already taken ownership.
You've signed off on it.
And for insurance purposes,
this is a very big deal.
So at what point
does legal ownership
of the asset transition?
You really have to know that.
And then, of course,
the training.
Checkout-- checkout means
turning on all your systems
and subsystems, making
sure everything works,
making sure there's no emergent
behaviors, weird behaviors,
unexpected behaviors.
Comparing the
predicted parameters
against the actual behaviors.
Does the system behave
as we had predicted,
based on calculations?
These days, we usually
build simulations.
We build a pretty realistic
simulation of the system,
and there's the concept
of digital twin.
Who's heard this before?
Digital twin.
Oh, nobody, OK.
So the idea of a digital
twin is that here's
your physical system,
airplane, satellite, cube sat,
whatever it is, medical device.
And there's a
digital twin of it.
There's a in silico
version, a simulated twin,
of that system that
exists somewhere.
And before you turn the system
on and do operations on it,
you do it on the
digital twin to see
what will happen and
predict everything--
all the parameters,
the position, velocity,
accelerations,
temperatures, pressures.
So if things look good
in the digital twin,
then you actually do
it in the real system.
So for example, JPL with their
Mars rovers, they will do that.
They have a digital twin,
they have a digital version.
They actually have
a physical twin too.
But they typically only use
that if there's problems,
like stuck in a sand dune
or something like that.
So you actually
simulate commands
that you're going to
send to the spacecraft
on your digital twin, make sure
that the command sequence is
correct, that things will--
and then you do it
on the real system.
That's what we mean here.
And during checkout,
you do it initially.
But actually, if it's
a very complex system,
you might do this as
a matter of routine.
And then sustainment is
the third thing here.
So sustainment means
maintenance, both preventative
and corrective.
So preventative
maintenance means
you're taking actions
before the system breaks.
Corrective action means you're
taking maintenance actions
after you have failures of
different kind-- spare parts
management, reconfiguring
system during use
for different purposes,
upgrading system,
and then retrofits.
So what is a retrofit?
Anybody know?
At EPFL, are you familiar
with the term retrofit?
Have you heard this word before?
Volcker, do you want to
explain what it means?
GUEST SPEAKER: Absolutely.
So for example, let's take your
[INAUDIBLE] system, the system
volt's M109.
Ours says from USA.
Back in the '60s, '70s, then
these things are aluminum,
launch self-propelled.
And in the '80s, '90s, they
decided to not throw them away.
They don't rust.
But to retrofit them, to
put guidance navigation
system, new cam.
So waiting through
a retrofit program,
meaning you sort of
break down everything,
down to the lowest elements,
you decide what you can keep.
You throw away the
obsolete stuff.
You buy new things,
and you try to make it.
PROFESSOR: Yup.
GUEST SPEAKER: And
then you reconfigure.
PROFESSOR: So retrofit
typically means
you physically go
out in the field,
and you physically
change the system.
Like Volcker said,
you remove things,
you typically add new things.
So now you have like old
generation and new generation
stuff mixed up in the system.
Retrofitting is a huge deal,
particularly in the military,
but in other domains as well,
like hospitals, infrastructure,
train systems.
You go there, and you
see a mix of old stuff
from when the system was
originally built and deployed,
and then new stuff layered on
top of it through retrofits.
And the key question, of course,
when you do a retrofit is,
you want the retrofit
not to interfere.
You want it to actually
be value added as opposed
to causing more problems.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is retrofit the
same as medium-life up grade?
PROFESSOR: I would
say it this way--
a medium-life or
middle-of-the-life upgrade is
a particular type of retrofit
that you do roughly halfway
through the nominal
mission life.
Yes, and do you have
experience with such upgrade?
AUDIENCE: Yes, actually we have
both F-5 and AMX in Brazil.
We have the medium-life upgrade
and both performed by Embraer.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So it's interesting
because the F-5, for example,
is Northrop.
And the medium-life upgrade
was performed by Embraer.
And we had lots of
issues about it.
PROFESSOR: So what was
done to the airplane?
AUDIENCE: Completely change
of the dashboard panels
and new electronic
warfare equipment.
But they kept the old
hydraulics engine and--
actually, hydraulics and engine.
The electrical system
was changed as well.
PROFESSOR: Was changed as well.
So you keep the
frame, the engine--
AUDIENCE: And you change
the radar, the antennas,
and lots of different stuff.
PROFESSOR: That makes sense.
That makes sense.
AUDIENCE: A new head-up display,
a new helmet, stuff like that.
PROFESSOR: The
interesting discussion,
which I think in the
US for much equipment,
and Switzerland
same discussions,
is by the time you start
adding up the cost of a midlife
upgrade or retrofit, you start
adding all these things up,
pretty quickly you
come to the question,
well, wow that's
pretty expensive.
Is it really worth it,
investing x millions or billions
to squeeze another 10, 15
years out of this platform?
Or should we just buy a new
one and retire this one?
And you'll have very
vigorous debates about that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just how does
the funding structure ever
come into play when
determining how sustainable,
or how you're going
to retrofit something?
I know sometimes,
where you worked
funding ends this time
and something else
starts up this time.
So sometimes, you kind
of design a little bit
around those things.
Is that ever taken
into consideration?
PROFESSOR: Well, I think
enlightened companies,
enlightened organizations will
actually build in retrofit
and upgrade costs into
their original budgets.
But does it happen often?
I think it's a minority of
organizations who really
are honest to think about
the full lifecycle cost,
including upgrades
and retrofits.
And to be honest,
sometimes, these retrofits,
it's hard to know about
them ahead of time.
In some cases you can predict
them, but in many cases,
it's more reactive.
In fact, I'll tell you
a story about the F-18.
These retrofits often come
in bundles or packages
called ECPs, Engineering
Change Proposals.
They're sort of
packages of changes.
And it's almost
blackmail, but it's
like, here's a bundle of changes
that is x million dollars.
And it's up to you whether you
want to implement that or not.
But if you choose
not to implement,
then the warranty is void.
Or you're losing compatibility
with any future upgrades.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So the configurations
then start to diverge.
And then you have to
make a tough decision.
Do you spend money on an upgrade
that maybe you don't absolutely
need, but some other
customers wanted?
And if you say no,
we don't want this.
We're going to freeze
the configuration
where we are today.
Then, you might lose the
option for future upgrades.
And if you then choose
to upgrade later,
it could be much more expensive.
And that's systems
engineering too.
And it gets into technical
issue, financial issues,
strategic issues.
So I hope you're getting a
sense here that this is all
happening during operations.
This is fascinating stuff.
This is not boring.
This is not just
routine operations.
OK, so in operations, we have
launch for spacecraft science
operations, safehold, anomaly
resolution, and so forth.
And I just want to show
you a quick video here
about the James Webb--
this is a one-minute video
about the anticipated deployment
of the James Webb Space
Telescope.
I think, I mentioned to you.
I've worked on this
as a Master's student.
This is supposed
to happen in 2018,
launch from Kourou
on an Ariane rocket.
This is a NASA-ISA
collaboration.
You can see right now, the
spacecraft has been launched.
It's deploying its sunshield.
These are very thin membranes.
The purpose of the sunshield
is to keep the optics cold.
The optics are on the top here.
And there's spreaders, and
there shouldn't be any wrinkles.
And there's multiple layers.
You can see the layers.
Now, first you spread
it out horizontally.
Now, the layers are
being spread to be
right at the right angles.
And I don't know what's
happening right now.
But the last step
that should happen--
I guess it didn't quite
play until the end.
But the last thing
that happens is
the optics are then deployed.
And the optical deployment
is also very, very involved
and has to be very precise.
So let me just minimize this.
So and then after that,
you have a commissioning.
I should also mention
that the James Webb State,
when I worked on it, it
was a $500-million mission.
It's now become an
$8-billion mission.
But the purpose
of this instrument
is to look back in time to
what's known as the dark ages.
It's basically like 300,000
years to about 100 million
years after the Big Bang.
The formation of the very
first Pluto galaxies.
We can't observe that right now
with Hubble or from the ground,
mainly because these
are so far away because
of the expansion of the
universe that the radiation is
redshifted.
And this is all in the infrared.
So you to have a very quiet,
very cold instrument to
see these first
proto-galaxies being formed.
So I know we can argue, is
it worth spending 8 billion
to see the very first
galaxy being formed or not?
People will debate it.
But the fact is, it's happening.
James Webb will launch.
And then, it's going to go
through a commissioning phase,
like I just talked about.
So I want you to answer
this question here.
How long do you think
the commissioning
phase of the James Webb
Space Telescope will take?
Three days, a week--
in orbit that is.
Three days, a week, three
weeks, a month, three months,
six months, or you're not sure.
So answer that question, and
then we'll take a short break,
like five minutes, and
look at the answer.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: Are they still on
schedule with the telescope?
Or do you have any
idea on whether that
will slip some more?
PROFESSOR: When I
worked on it, it
was supposed to launch in 2008.
But I do think--
I mean, the spacecraft is
being integrated right now
at Northrop Grumman.
We saw it in January.
So they're not lying
to us, I think.
They're actually
putting things together.
And I think, it's
going to launch in 20--
maybe slip by another
six months, or maybe
a year but not more.
I don't think so.
Basically, how long does
it take from what you just
saw in the video until
PIs, Principal Investigator
scientists--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Can start using it.
PROFESSOR: --can start
using it for real science.
How long will that take?
So who wants to respond?
Who thinks it's like a
month, three weeks, a week?
A month or less?
Who responded to
that, a month or less.
Go ahead.
What were you thinking?
AUDIENCE: No specific idea.
PROFESSOR: What
were you imagining
would happen in a month?
AUDIENCE: I thought that
it couldn't be very, very
long because if the objective
is to collect the data,
you can't wait that much
before you start using it.
But I had no specific ideas.
PROFESSOR: No, I think
that's a good answer.
You deploy the solar panels,
the sunshield, the optics,
the spacecraft's
at the right place.
By the way, this is
going to launch too
in Earth-trailing orbit,
like Earth-Sun L2, kind
of trailing orbit.
So it's kind of away from the
Earth, from albedo, all that.
So you deployed it,
let's get on with it.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I agree.
And then I think, 37%
of you, a third of you
thought maybe three months,
and then 40% about six months.
All right, so let's look
at the current plans.
And I took some slides here--
I referenced it--
from a lady that
works at the Space Telescope
Science Institute that's
located in Baltimore,
the NASA's Goddard Space
Center of Baltimore.
This is from last year.
So here's the plan to
launch in October of 2018,
and then do the deployment.
And the answer is
right now six months.
Six months commissioning phase--
and then, there's
different cycles
of-- so GO stands
for guest observer.
So you have primary PIs.
They usually get first dibs.
And then you have observing
time for guest observers.
Here's another little
bit more detail.
So full schedule of deployment
and check-out activities,
a limited set of
science calibration
ops possible, science
observations highly unlikely
during this six-months phase.
And then, you have this
Guest Observer Program,
and there's a budget, actually,
Guaranteed Time Observation
Program from April of 2019--
a total of 3,960 hours
allocated in the first 30 months
after commissioning, OK?
And so those 3,960 hours are--
people will fight over this.
And there's a very
detailed process
for how to allocate and compete
for that observation time.
But the answer
here is six months.
And it really surprised
me too that it's
going to take this long but
the reason it takes so long
is mainly calibration.
Calibration is a big thing.
You want to make sure that
all the observations you're
going to take are correct.
And in order to do a
proper calibration,
you have to essentially image
things that have already
been imaged before by other
instruments that were also
properly calibrated.
So that for a known
set of targets,
you know you're getting
the same answer.
And that just takes time.
I think, in a nutshell,
that's the main reason it
takes so long.
GUEST SPEAKER: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: Yup, go ahead.
GUEST SPEAKER: There's
also the one aspect
with this observatory is that
you have to be stabilized.
And as you get to bring it
up from Earth, even though it
was pulled together in a
clean, very high [INAUDIBLE],,
it's going to have to deploy.
And then, just to get to
the chemical stabilization,
it's going to spend weeks
before they even can start
to calibrate the instruments.
So for you to get
the outgassing,
the whole volatile
substances and get
that they move far away, not
from the spacecraft, that they
dilute in space, get
stabilization of temperature,
and then you can only
start checking instruments.
PROFESSOR: Great point.
So thermal stability,
outgassing--
so really everything
is very stable.
Yeah, very good point.
OK, so let me talk briefly.
I'm going to go through
two examples of research
in operations.
And then, we'll talk about
the post-flight review.
All right, so the first thing
is, each of these two examples
are based on papers.
So "Spare parts requirements
for space missions
with reconfigurability
and commonality."
This is based on a paper
in Journal of Spacecraft
and Rockets, 2007.
So and this work was done during
the Constellation Program which
was, we're going to
go back to the moon.
We will re-establish a
human presence on the moon.
And we're going to bring
a whole bunch of stuff
with us, more than we did
during Apollo to do this.
So the picture on
the upper-right,
you see a habitat on
top of a Lander stage.
You see an Ascent Vehicle
with a Lander stage.
You see a Rover that looks kind
of similar to the Lunar Rover,
but there's also a
pressurized version of it.
So we're going to bring
a whole bunch of stuff.
And the challenge is during
operations, things will break.
So you need to bring spare
parts to support all this.
And some recent research
we've done in my group
shows that for Mars,
it's the same problem.
You're going to stay
there a long time.
You don't know exactly
what will break.
But if you want a
high probability
of being able to
successfully operate,
you do need to bring spares.
So the idea that was explored
here is, what if those spares
could be common
or reconfigurable
and you can do scavenging?
So the idea is that, instead
of bringing a dedicated spare--
if you give these
three systems that
are shown here, The Habitat, the
Ascent Vehicle, and the Rover,
to three different
companies to build,
and they don't
talk to each other,
and you don't impose any
commonality requirements,
you're going to get very
different solutions.
What's the classic
example of this
in spaceflight,
human spaceflight?
Apollo 13.
What happened in Apollo 13?
The cartridges for
the CO2 scrubbing,
square cartridges
versus round cartridges.
The two different contractors,
they didn't talk to each other.
The government didn't say you
have to make these common,
so they weren't common.
So the idea here is,
what is the effect
of reconfigurable and common
spares on system availability
if you allow temporary
scavenging and cannibalization
of systems that aren't used?
And so one thing you need for
that is an operational profile
for each element.
And that's shown
in the lower left.
So this is essentially a binary.
Zero means that particular
element is dormant
or not being used.
It's kind of in slumber mode.
And 1 means it's
actively being used.
And so then we have at each
of these time periods, T1, T2,
T3--
our time periods where
there is a change
in the operational status
of a particular element.
Either it goes from sleeping
mode to active mode,
or from active mode
to inactive mode.
And so knowing these
cycles' operational profiles
is very important
to do the analysis.
So this is a little
bit of math here.
I'm not going to go
through this in detail.
But basically, when you
do classical sparing,
and maintainability,
and failure analysis,
you assume that failures arrive
according to a Poisson process.
So this is the equation
for a Poisson distribution.
And then you can see the various
variables that are used here.
So your lambda is
your failure rate.
P of n is the probability
they have exactly n failures.
And then, down here,
we have the spares
that are available to you.
And really spares can come
from two different sources.
One is, you bring spares
with you from Earth.
So this is a spares from
repository, s sub i.
These are spares you brought
with you as a pool of spares.
And then s sub e are spares
that you take out of elements
that are not being used.
So these are spares that
are scavenged temporarily
from inactive elements.
That's s sub e
minus n sub f, which
is the number of failures that
have occurred up to that point.
So the total number of
spares available at any given
point in time is your
initial spares pool
plus spares you can
scavenge from other inactive
elements in the
system, minus elements
that have already failed.
And this is assuming no
repair, so you can't repair.
And it assumes that you
know ahead of time what
the operational profile is.
So there's spares
available from elements
from scavenging is
this equation here.
It's essentially the sum
over all the elements,
E. E is the number of
elements in your architecture.
Q sub E is something known as
quantity per application, QPA
also.
So basically, if you have
like a mission computer
or in like UAVs, we have servos.
Like, this particular
element has
six servos, identical servos.
They're used on the vehicle.
So QPA, this QE would be 6.
So if that element
isn't used, we
could go in, take out a servo,
put it in somewhere else.
And so we can treat that
as a spare, at least
during the period where
that UAV isn't used.
Does that make sense?
OK, so the difference
then is that in the kind
of classic way of doing it,
we have dedicated spares.
Each element, one element
1, element i, element E,
has dedicated spares that
only work on that vehicle.
There's no swapping,
there's no scavenging,
there's no communality.
And therefore, your spares
repository, s sub i,
is going to be pretty
big because there's
no commonality, no sparing.
In this new situation, you have
reconfigurable or common parts.
So we still have a
spares repository.
But now those spares can be
deployed across all or a subset
of the elements,
plus we can treat--
and this is this
dashed line here--
we can treat elements that
are part of idle elements.
We can treat them
temporarily as being
part of the spares repository.
Does that make sense?
So that's a much more, in
a sense, smarter way to do.
And the question is,
what's the benefit of this?
So in order to calculate
the benefits for this,
we essentially--
we have some constraints.
So for example, the number
of failures that you can have
is between--
if you have zero
failures, that's great.
That's your lower floor.
And then N is the
total number of units
you have in your
architecture, including
the ones in the inventory,
in the initial inventory,
and plus the ones that are
built into all the vehicles.
And then, the key here is what's
known as back-order level.
So back-order essentially
is the number of spares
that you would
need but may not--
so when the back-order level
becomes larger than zero,
it essentially means that
your number of failures
have exceeded the number
of spares that you have.
You don't have enough
spares to satisfy
all your operational needs.
So this is this conditional
back-order at spares level s.
And you sum that
essentially then
over all the possible failure
states that you could see.
And why is that useful?
Because you can then
calculate essentially
your element availability.
So a is your availability
of at time ti.
And then your probability
of the whole system
is the minimum of your system
availability at any time
and point during your mission
horizon, your mission time,
T. Do you see how that works?
So you have your spares.
You have failures of the
spares, which are random.
And then you can
calculate, are you
going to have enough spares to
operate every element that you
need to operate when it's
supposed to be operational?
And the back-order level, this
number b here, is what you use.
You look at your back-order
level across the whole mission
timeline to see what your
system availability will be.
And there's a closed form
approximation of this.
And then for a larger number
of elements and different QPAs
and so forth, you typically then
have to switch to simulation,
like Monte Carlo simulations.
So what are the results here?
So this was applied to--
the example here is a
co-located mission elements.
This is for, I think,
it was a lunar mission.
And you define essentially
the operational time profile,
quantity per application,
and so forth.
And the example that was used
was an electronic control unit,
and ECU, with a meantime to
failure of 100,000 hours.
So failure rate is 1
over meantime to failure.
Lambda is the
expected failure rate
is 1 over meantime to failure.
So pretty reliable,
100,000 hours
of operation meantime to
failure is pretty reliable.
But of course, you're
far from Earth.
This is a 600-day
timeline, and you
can see here the
operational profiles
for your various
mission elements.
So this is actually kind of
reminds you of The Martian,
right?
Anybody seen the movie
The Martian recently?
Who's seen The Martian?
Who's not seen The Martian?
You've got to go.
You're the only one in the room.
It's a great movie.
So he does scavenging
and even things
that weren't supposed
to be scavenged.
And so we have
four elements here.
We have the PR, which is the
Pressurized Rover, the Habitat,
the All-Terrain
Vehicle, and then
the ATV, which is the
Ascent-Descent Vehicle.
In this case, it's the same
vehicle for ascent and descent.
And so the
Ascent-Descent Vehicle,
you only need it when you
land and when you depart.
The rest of the
time it's dormant.
The Habitat is used while
you're on the surface.
The ATV is used while
And then, the Pressurized
Rover is used--
the assumption here
is you're going
to operate for like 100
days very close to the base.
And only after 100
days are you going
to start going further away
with the Pressurized Rover.
So those are the
operational profiles.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there an
argument that you wouldn't
want to be scavenging parts
from your Ascent-Descent Vehicle
at all?
PROFESSOR: That's a good point.
So if basically, your
back-order level is too high,
and you run out of
your last spare the day
before you're supposed to launch
on the ADV, you're in trouble.
But if that's the case,
then what you have to do
is you have to
exclude the minimum--
and there may be redundancy
in that Ascent Vehicle.
And you may or may not
be willing to sacrifice
the redundancy.
I mean, this is all
about risk, right?
And exclude those or keep out
spares that you cannot touch
because if you can't, then
you can't get back home.
So you just don't count
those in your spares pool
if that's the case.
But you can still do
the whole analysis.
OK, so what's the
bottom line here?
What's the punch line here?
So the punch line is
that if you have a--
the D case here is the
dedicated case, OK?
So this is where
there's no scavenging,
there's no commonality of
spares among these elements.
You have to have
dedicated spares.
And let's assume you want
a 90% availability, which
is not that high.
That's a relatively
modest requirement.
You want 90% availability.
What it means is you need
to have in this case,
you can see the
line just crosses
below here, this crossover.
You need four spares in
your initial spares pool
for this electronic
control unit.
You have to have at least
four spares, dedicated spares,
for that electronic control
unit for a 600-day mission
for a unit that has
100,000 MTTF or MTBF
to guarantee at least
90% availability.
And you say, oh,
that's not a big deal.
That's just four spares.
Well, that's just one unit.
That's just one box, right?
You probably have
dozens of boxes,
or even hundreds across
all these elements.
And so that could
be a lot of spares.
You translate that to mass
and volume, that's a big deal.
So using closed-form analytics
to calculate the minimum number
of spares you need,
this is the R case,
the reconfigurable case.
You can see that you can
achieve that same requirement
with two spares.
You see that?
That's this line here.
It's this line here, and
this is a conservative model.
This is a conservative model.
So by doing reconfigurable and
common spares and scavenging,
you can cut your number
of spares in half.
You can cut your number
of spares in half
and still achieve a 90%
system availability.
And then you multiply that
across all the elements
in your architecture.
And that's a big deal.
And then this result here--
so this is a rigorous
bound because it
makes some conservative
assumptions,
and it uses closed-form
equations to calculate this.
And the details
are in the paper.
And then this curve
here is the simulated.
So if you simulate this using
essentially a discrete event
simulation several times,
and then you take averages,
it's actually even
a little better.
This suggests you could even
get away with one spare.
But it's not as conservative
as the closed-form solution.
OK, so the bottom line
is reconfigurable parts
allow for 33% to 50% reduction
in the number of required
spares for 90%
availability level.
But if you think about what
that means operationally,
it means that you really
have to know ahead
of time what's going to be
operational when, you have
to have the crew trained
to be able to actually go
in and scavenge.
And the equipment,
the vehicles, have
to be designed such that you
can actually remove this stuff
and put it back in
relatively easily.
So that would impose
some accessibility,
and replaceability, and
maintainability requirements.
The other option is you
say, we don't want spares.
Well, then you need to
do a lot of redundancy.
And then, your
vehicles are going
to get heavy and more complex.
I mean, those are the
real world trade-offs.
Yup, Sam?
AUDIENCE: Does this
potentially increase
the risk for the
crew of the mission
if there's some sort of inherent
failure in the particular part
that is being used everywhere?
PROFESSOR: So I don't know if
you looked ahead or you just--
I know you're a smart guy, Sam.
So this is the answer to
your question right here.
So this is great.
OK, we like the fact
that we can cut down
on the number of
spares and still meet
the same availability.
But you can ask the
question in different ways.
So on the left side is a
kind of sensitivity analysis
that says, well, maybe we're
not so mass constrained.
We have plenty of
transportation capacity.
So we're not really
mass constrained.
But we know that designing
ultra-reliable electronic boxes
or whatever components
is very expensive, right?
So can we decrease
the requirement
on the manufacturer
of these boxes?
And can we go from, say,
100,000 to 75,000 MTTF?
So we're decreasing the nominal
reliability of the equipment
by a fourth.
We're making the job easier
for the supplier of that box.
Presumably, that
should be cheaper.
That should be a cheaper
box to design and build.
So what will happen if we drop
the reliability requirement
by 25%?
And then you can
see the impact here.
So the blue curve
is essentially what
you get for the less
reliable equipment.
And then the black
was the original.
So now, Sam's question.
So this is basically-- so
here's your failure rate.
OK, this is your failure
rate, 10 to the minus 3.
And we're varying the failure
rate over a large range.
And then we're looking
at system availability.
This is for a fixed
number of spares.
And what's really interesting--
so when your failure rate is
low--
so we're on the left side--
then the blue curve is
lower, the dedicated case.
So for a fixed number of
spares, for relatively reliable
equipment, you're better off
going with the reconfigurable
or common spares.
This is logarithmic, so
it's a little tricky.
So system availability
is higher when
you have common and
reconfigurable spares,
relatively reliable equipment.
But there's a crossover point.
If your boxes, your
elements, your components,
are very unreliable, which
is on the right side,
there's actually
a crossover point.
And the idea is that,
well, now because it's
common and reconfigurable
across all the vehicles,
you have this really bad box
that breaks all the time.
Now, the problem is everywhere.
Every vehicle, everything
is affected by it.
Whereas before, it was kind
of more contained, right?
And so that's what
that crossover is.
So if you're in a situation
with very unreliable equipment,
unreliable components,
you're actually
worse off making them
common or reconfigurable.
And you can now calculate
where that crossover point is.
That's pretty cool,
don't you think?
I get excited about this stuff.
I don't know about you
guys, but this is real.
This is what you care--
in operations, this is--
how many spares of
each kind, can we
guarantee that we
can successfully
do this campaign, whether
it's a military campaign,
or you go to Antarctica.
And we heard about
the Octanus Rover.
And it's just one
Rover, but what's
all this stuff that you need
to bring with you in terms
of spares to make
sure you can actually
have a successful campaign
and have a guarantee of that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if the
reconfigurability argument also
has some sort of impact
on the kind of finances
and manufacturability--
in terms of if you're
making reconfigurable
parts for different things,
they may be more
similarly manufactured,
and therefore may represent
a decrease in cost
on the manufacturing side?
If that's another motivation.
PROFESSOR: That's a great point.
What I will say
about that is that
in order to capture
that benefit,
you need to lock that
in contractually.
So either you give all this
work to the same manufacturer
and say, OK, you're now making
50 boxes instead of just five.
There has to be a discount
on a per-unit basis for that.
Or if it's different
manufacturers,
then it gets hard.
So yes, but you have to have the
kind of business arrangements
that will allow you
to capture that value.
EPFL-- were you
able to follow this?
I know this is pretty
detailed discussion
here on these curves.
Is it-- Maxim, you're
sort of shaking your head.
Is it clear?
GUEST SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]--
I can give you a concrete
practical about everyday life
example that you probably know
about in this particular view
of [INAUDIBLE].
But imagine you go with your
car on vacation for two weeks,
and your children all
need Pampers [INAUDIBLE]..
And you can take them
with you from your store.
Well, you know how they are.
They are more
expensive but reliable.
But you don't know how many
you're going to consume.
But you get a certain
minimum amount per day,
and you hope you don't
go over the limit.
Now, it takes lots of volume.
So you have to trade off
your space because you
have fixed space in your car.
You cannot take more than
the volume available.
And so this is exactly the kind
of reliability curve you have.
You can take too
little with you.
You have to buy the wrong
stuff when you get there,
wherever you are.
And then it might have leaks
and failures and not worth it.
So you'll need more than
what you thought initially
and cost more as well.
So actually, this is extremely
important in everyday life.
PROFESSOR: OK, so I like your--
I'm past that stage with
my kids several years.
GUEST SPEAKER: Me too.
PROFESSOR: But I'm going
to amend your example
in the following way.
Basically, if you had two kids,
and they're very different,
like one is really tall, and
their same diapers will not
fit, then you have
a problem, right?
But if they're twins, or if you
buy stretchable diapers that
have a huge range, then
you can cut down, right?
So you have to have like
different kids in the car.
Then it works.
I think then the example works.
OK, let's see.
We're kind of running
short on time.
So one more example.
This is based on the doctoral
thesis of Jeremy [? Oktay. ?]
He's a flight test engineer.
And the question
that he looked at
was robustness of
degraded airplanes.
So the idea here is
that some systems
are going to be used longer
in long, ultra-endurance kind
of systems where you do not
have the option of repair.
You don't have the option
to land, repair, and fix
the system, and bring
it back to its pristine
everything-is-working state.
And on the right side here, you
see some examples of-- these
are real systems that
people have worked on,
or are working on,
or are thinking
about that have this situation.
The DARPA Vulture is a program
where a UAV would stay aloft
for five years with no
landing and a repair allowed.
So you can obviously see
it's got solar panels,
and I think it has fuel cells
as well, if I'm not mistaken.
So how do you achieve that?
This is an example from
Antarctica flying several UAVs
to map the ice sheets.
This was a gap solution
while the iSat satellite
between iSat I and iSat II.
And then here's a human
colony maybe on the moon
or looks like the moon.
So we have this dome here.
This crater has been
covered with a dome,
and we have a greenhouse inside.
So life support
systems that have
to be super reliable for a
very long amount of time.
And so the question
that Jeremy looked at
is, how do we
design and optimize
systems that have ultra-long
endurance, where you know ahead
of time that
failures will occur?
Failures will occur, and you
can't repair the failures
easily.
So you have to design
the system apriori,
such that in those
partially-failed states,
it will give you the
maximum residual performance
that it possibly could.
And it turns out, when that's
your objective function,
you design the
systems differently
than if you just optimize
nominal performance
and then worry about what
happens if there's failures.
And this is the second paper
that I uploaded for you.
So both of these papers
"The Reconfigurable Spares"
and then this one are uploaded
both on Moodle and Stellar
if you want to
take a deeper look.
So the case study
here is the C-12--
this is the King Air airplane.
This is the military
version of it
and typically flies out
of Edwards Air Force base.
And the idea is that there
can be different failures
on this airplane.
So this diagram, this is
a so-called Markov chain
where n means nominal.
And you can see the table
that goes with this.
Nominal means
nothing has failed,
and you just do turn control.
This is climbing,
left-turn climbing.
You just turn control
with your ailerons,
which is just standard flying.
And then different
failures could
occur of different elements.
So the left engine, the rudder,
and the aileron could fail.
Of course, a lot more can fail.
But in this case study,
those are the elements
that are allowed to fail.
And so 1 means the
left engine has failed,
2 means the rudder
has failed, and 3
means the ailerons have failed.
And then as you move to the
right, it gets worse and worse.
So state 4 means you lost your
left engine and the aileron,
but you still have your rudder.
And then, the worst is state
7, where everything's failed.
The left engine's
failed, the rudder,
and the aileron has failed.
And what you worry about is
what we call availability.
Expected availability is what's
the probability or fraction
of probability that
the system will
perform above some minimum
threshold, which in this case
we call WM.
And then expected performance
is the probability of each
of these failure states
multiplied by the performance
that you're still getting
in that failure state, OK?
And what was done
here is to say, OK,
we know what the
C-12 airplane looks
like the way it exists today.
But what if that
airplane had been
designed slightly differently?
Low value and high value
around the baseline,
a little bit bigger
wing, bigger tail--
how would it impact the
performance, not just
the nominal, but the off-nominal
performance in these failed
states?
So just to show you why this
is interesting or relevant--
I picked out the most
interesting failure
states are the
intermediate ones here,
these partially-failed states.
And so on this
picture, you can see
in red what's failed
on the aircraft,
and then plotting bank angle
versus specific excess power,
which is essentially
your ability
to climb in feet per minute.
And this is all calculated
through a simulator,
a pretty accurate six degree
of freedom simulator, where
you can actually
modify the airplane.
It's a very cool
open-source simulator
that Jeremy modified where you
can actually fly the airplane
simulated, and you can change
the plane during flight.
Like you could grow
the wings as the plane
is flying-- like morphing
wings and things like this.
And of course here, you
fail parts of the airplane
during flight.
And then, the flight dynamics
are automatically the physics,
automatically you have to
adjust to that failure.
So this is not like
spreadsheet-type analysis,
just so you know.
So if you're inside
the safe region here,
then you can keep the
bank angle between--
we defined it between
25 and 35 degrees--
and you have positive
rate of climb.
Then you're still
in the safe region.
And each of these points here
is a slightly tweaked version
of the baseline airplane.
So what's interesting here
is in some of these states,
you're outside of
the safe region.
So a small difference in the
design of the nominal airplane
will mean the difference
between losing the plane
or still being able to fly.
So these points
that are out here,
these are the interesting
points because they
fall outside the safe region.
And the points inside are
inside the safe region.
Everything is the same
except the airplane geometry
has been tweaked.
And then of course, state
7 everything has failed.
You lose the airplane.
There's no way to
recover the airplane.
So in some cases,
it's very clean.
It's very clear
what will happen.
And these intermediate
failure states
are the interesting ones
because small changes
in the upfront design make
a big difference in how
the airplane will perform in
a partially-degraded state
or partially-failed state.
So the other thing
you can do then
is you can do a sensitivity
analysis and say, well,
how sensitive is, for
example, expected performance
to the various design
variables in the airplane?
Like rudder cord, and I'll
talk about vertical tail here,
and the engine failure
rate, and so forth.
And the difference between
the yellow and the green
is yellow is an
eight-hour mission.
So this is a typical
You fly, you come back.
And if something's failed,
you just repair it.
In the 20,000 mission,
20,000-hour mission,
you can't come back and repair.
So what you see
here is interesting.
It means the sensitivity of
performance to these design
decisions depends on how long
you will operate the system.
And because the longer you
operate it, the more likely
is that it will see these
partial failure modes, which
will then influence the degraded
or the residual performance
of the airplane.
And the most interesting
parameter here,
if you just look at this diagram
beside the engine failure
rate-- so the engine failure
rate matters a lot when you fly
a 20,000-hour mission.
But if you look at the
cross these parameters,
which one of these is
the most interesting?
Which one of these is the
most interesting parameter?
Let's see at EPFL.
Can you see this diagram?
Which one of these parameters
is the most interesting?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The vertical tail?
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because it
has different behavior
for the lifecycle and just
for the single mission.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So if you're only going to
fly short missions with it
and then land and
repair, you see
the sensitivity is off
to the left, slightly
negative sensitivity.
So you could actually make
it just a little bit smaller.
But if you're going
to fly very long,
you should actually
make it bigger.
And this particular airplane
has an undersized vertical tail.
It has a Dutch roll
mode, where it has a yaw
damper that was added later.
And so if you're going to
fly for a long time period,
you're going to see a failure
mode that will then exasperate
that particular failure mode.
So what it means is that if
you're actually going to design
this airplane for a 20,000-hour
mission that you would design
a much larger vertical
tail which penalizes you
in the nominal.
It penalizes you in
nominal operations,
but it will benefit you in
these partially-failed states.
Does that make
sense to you guys?
You guys were
laughing, or smiling,
or thinking about this.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it does.
PROFESSOR: So have you
flown this airplane?
Or do you have experience in it?
AUDIENCE: We did a
flight test course,
and we tested that troll.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this brought
up some fuzzy memories or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I mean, it's
basically the wing tip
does like a figure eight.
That's sort of classic.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: That's the classic
manifestation of Dutch roll.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: But if the
Dutch roll is too big,
you can actually
lose the airplane.
You can induce an instability.
So this is a big deal.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would that mean
that the vertical tail
is sized properly then?
Because you can make it
smaller and get a little better
in this area, or make it
bigger and get a little better
in this area.
Because It seems like the
vertical, like, other things--
PROFESSOR: It's fine
with the yaw damper.
It's fine with the yaw damper.
But actually, there has
been an airplane lost.
There has been an
airplane lost in flight.
And the accident
investigation showed
that it was basically a Dutch
roll mode that became unstable.
And so the point here is,
if you have a failure,
then you're in trouble with
the small vertical tail.
But if you don't have a failure,
then you're probably OK.
And that's the whole point
of me showing you this--
is to make the point that if you
are going to deal with a system
or operate a system that is
going to have a very long
operational life,
long endurance,
without the possibility to land,
repair, and send it back out--
so it's going to be perfect
and pristine on day one.
And then gradually,
stuff will fail,
and that's the case for
infrastructure, bridges,
spacecraft past Neptune,
airplanes that are going
to be aloft for five years.
You just have to design
them differently.
You just have to design-- and
this is hard for engineers
to think about-- that I'm
actually designing for failure.
I am designing a
system expecting
that it will partially fail, not
completely, but partially fail.
And by taking that into account,
the design looks different.
This is kind of
non-conventional.
OK, final thing,
post-flight review--
what happens at the post-flight
or post-launch review?
PLR, PFR.
So essentially, what you do
is you review the telemetry
from flight.
You compare against
your predictions.
You find repair any failures.
You secure the
data for later use.
And then you initiate the
detailed commissioning and
hand-over to Operations.
And here's a detailed list of
entrance and success criteria
for post-flight review.
And I put this up here because
those of you that will actually
go to the CanSat competition,
this is part of the package.
You are expected to launch
your payload, do the flight,
and if something goes wrong, you
can maybe have a backup flight.
And then after the flight,
you do a post-flight review.
And good post-flight
reviews are planned ahead.
You already know what data
you're going to analyze,
if you already
have your software
ready to suck in the
data after the flight
and really get
insights out of it.
Summary here-- this is
just kind of a checklist
for thinking about operations.
System check-out and
the lab, hangar, field--
is everything working OK?
Bring sufficient consumables,
spare parts, tools,
support equipment, remote
control, telemetry, cameras.
Train the operators
and support personnel.
Checklists for
nominal operations
and routine emergency
and contingencies.
Think about your
transportation logistics
and plan enough time for a
ramp-up for commissioning
before operations.
OK, so that was all I
wanted to cover today.
Any questions about
commissioning and operations?
My main point in
this lecture today
was to kind of get you
excited about operations
and to highlight that
there's a lot here.
System engineers are not done.
After CDR or PDR, you
say, oh, I did my job
as a system engineer.
It's up to you
guys, the operators.
No, no, this is territory for
system engineering as well.
And in the end, you just have
to get operational experience.
There's no substitute
for actually being out
in the field operating systems
and getting that experience.
Any questions or
comments about this?
OK, so a quick reminder,
a quick reminder,
we're going to have our PDR.
You saw the schedule.
Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, please log
in five minutes before.
We're going to be using
my WebEx Personal Room.
The link is here.
Upload your slide deck.
30 minutes presentation,
and then we
have up to 30 minutes
of Q&A. All right?
Questions?